[Musique]
j'ai pas honte de le dire je suis fan de
green lantern même le film avec ryan
reynolds et les bien aimés
voilà et j'ai aussi rechuté sur le café
complètement rechuté sur le café et puis
aussi on va parler du nouveau macbook
pro le 16 pouces si j'ai plein de choses
à vous dire à propos de ce mac et ça
sera juste après l'intro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça lui léguant derrière et quand
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
moi encore je suis ravie comme toujours
comme toujours de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle vidéo
oui ça fait plaisir de vous voir là tous
dans le voilà moi je veux pas je vous me
voyez je vous vois pas mais on se voit
quoi enfin vous voyez le voilà et si
vous adorez faire des vidéos cette
chaîne elle est faite pour vous il faut
absolument que vous vous abonniez en
cliquant sur le petit bouton la cloche
tout ça tout ça parce que il ya plein de
choses qui vont vous intéressez sur
cette chaîne c'est sûr tu es obligé il
ya quelques mois je vous avais fait une
vidéo sur le set up que j'avais monté à
base de mac mini de iger p u d'écran
externe et tout ça et tout ça est juste
avant de commencer je tiens à préciser
que cette vidéo ne contredit pas la
précédente vidéo sur le mac mini c'est
complètement autre chose et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi justement j'ai
revendu le mac mini et pourquoi j'ai
acheté un macbook pro 16 pouces à quatre
mille balles ça pique
on va donc essayer de répondre à la
question est ce que ce macbook pro 16
pouces c'est l'ami des vidéastes qu'est
ce que ça donne niveau performance à qui
il est destiné
pourquoi passer d'un mac mini par
exemple ou d'une solution fixe à une
solution portable voilà des questions
auxquelles on va essayer de répondre
sachant que je vous donne ici à mon avis
en fonction de mon usage 1 qui sera
peut-être pas forcément le même pour
tout le monde dont bien entendu basse et
à prendre en fonction aussi de vos
usages avouent qu'ils sont peut-être pas
forcément les mêmes que les miens et le
modèle dont je vais vous parler c'est la
version donc 16 pouces avec un 8 coeurs
enough à 2.3 giguère une carte graphique
radeon 5500m 8 gigas et un ssd interne
de deux terrains sachant que là on n'est
pas loin de la version full options on
aurait pu aller encore un petit peu plus
loin dans le processus il ya une option
avec un processeur un tout petit peu
plus puissant et on aurait pu aussi lui
rajouter 64 giga de ram
le disque dur va même jusqu'à huit
terrains sauf que enfin déjà deux
terrasses et pas donné alors oui terra
c'est très cool hein d'avoir huit
terrains moi j'adorerais avoir lu
terrain dans mon macbook mais en deux
terrasses et déjà peu plus raisonnables
on va en reparler
et c'est parti on va rentrer dans le vif
du sujet on va aborder trois points
majeurs de ce macbook pro 13 pouces
on va parler ergonomie et mobilité on va
parler performance et après on va
essayer de voir un petit peu à qui
s'adresse ce macbook pro et pour qui
peut être vraiment un bon blanc alors
par rapport à mon set précédent ce
mabhouh pro il a un énorme avantage et
je vais enfants c'est une énorme porte
ouverte
tenez vous prêts accrochez vous ce
macbook pro il est portable
ouais c'est je sais c'est quoi c'est fou
c'est voix c'est un macbook et macbook
portable non plus sérieusement dans mon
métier de vidéastes j'ai de plus en plus
de demandes pour des livraisons rapides
de vidéos ou de photos aussi
et par conséquent dans le train il ya
une énorme perte de temps pour moi si je
dois attendre d'être rentré chez moi
pour vider mes cartes pour commencer mon
montage l'avantagé c'est qu'avec ce
macbook pro je peux directement commencé
à travailler quand je suis dans le train
quand je viens de finir ajouté j'ai pas
besoin d'attendre d'être chez moi et un
truc particulièrement cool dans cette
nouvelle mouture la des macbook puisque
précédemment été sur une gamme de 15
pouces avec des bords beaucoup plus
large là on est passé sur 16 pouces on
pourrait se dire que ben a passé de 15
pouces 16 pouces c'est pas si énorme que
ça ben là pour le coup quand on est en
train de monter en mobilité justement
sur un portable le moindre espace
d'écran supplémentaires il est
appréciable
et clairement là on est vraiment sur un
écran qui est très très très agréable et
le petit gain de place bien ma foi pour
avoir eu un macbook pro 15 pouces
d'ancienne génération c'est vraiment
vraiment pas négligeable ça change quand
même un peu les choses
et là-dessus apple a vraiment bien joué
son coup puisque la taille finalement de
ce macbook pro 16 pouces reste très
similaire à celle du macbook pro 15
pouces il est un petit peu plus épais il
est un petit peu plus lourd mais en
terme de taille tout simplement on peut
le voir quand on utilise des anciennes
mais comme on appelle ça ou ce deus mais
tout simplement on peut se rendre compte
qu'en termes de taille de volume
ce macbook pro il rentrait bien dans les
housses de macbook pro 15 pouces
donc ça montre bien que ni vos
empreintes on n'est pas sur quelque
chose de très très différents voire même
sur la même chose avec plus d'espacé
d'écran alors comme toujours je rentre
pas dans les caractéristiques techniques
pas sur une chaîne de teck
il ya des gens qui font ça très bien
d'ailleurs je vous mets des liens dans
la description de gens qui ont fait des
super vidéo là sur ce macbook pro nous
on va s'intéresser vraiment à l'aspect
je suis vidéaste est ce que le macbook
pro 13 pouces il va m'amener des choses
qui sont cools et qui vont me permettre
de faire mon boulot un peu mieux tant
qu'on est sur le point justement cette
augmentation de poids elle est en partie
due à une augmentation de la taille de
la batterie ce qui est tout à fait
appréciable puisque monter des vidéos ça
prend beaucoup de ressources ça bouffe
beaucoup de batteries donc le moindre
petit surplus le moindre petit gain en
batterie ben c'est toujours appréciable
et même si uniquement sur batterie on va
pas pouvoir faire de la vidéo pendant
des heures et des heures on va pouvoir
quand même travaillé deux bonnes heures
c'est un secteur ce qui est plutôt pas
mal sachant que la plupart du temps
trouver une prise c'est pas très très
compliqué non plus ça rend ce macbook
encore plus pertinente parce que voilà
une session de deux heures de travail en
débrancher c'est plutôt pas mal c'est
des performances qui sont vraiment hyper
respectable et qu'on retrouve pas chez
beaucoup d'autres concurrents en termes
de portable un autre point assez sympa
même si moi je préfère utiliser le
clavier et la souris pour monter on a un
trackpad géants comme sur les
précédentes générations qui est hyper
confortable du coup on arrive à se
balader dans la timeline assez
facilement
on n'a pas vraiment un tout petit truc
ou sur lequel on va galérer à faire les
choses avec le doigt là on a quand même
quelque chose d'assez conséquent puis a
toujours les gestes de zoom de des
hommes qui sont assez pratique pour le
montage je vais pas vous parler des
masses de la touch barre parce que je ne
m'en sers pas pour moi c'est quelque
chose de complètement accessoire et de
complètement gadgets vraiment mais ils
n'y seraient pas ça me changerait
strictement rien alors c'est peut-être
moi avec mes habitudes
qui n'arrivent pas à attirer le
potentiel de sa d'ailleurs dit moi vous
dans les commentaires si vous utilisez
la tête du bar des macbook pour monter
parce que moi j'ai déjà j'ai essayé
vraiment j'ai essayé et ce nom à mon
sens c'est pas un argument à prendre en
compte si vous envisagez d'acheter ce
macbook pro donc pour résumer en termes
d'ergonomie et de côté purement pratique
il est vraiment pas très très lourd
quand même pour un ordi de cette taille
là il est plutôt autonome
même si la majeure partie du temps on
l'utilisera pas comme ça on a vraiment
un backup de batterie on va dire qui est
largement suffisant pour bien avancer
même dans des conditions un peu speed où
on a un petit peu la pression l'écran
est vraiment agréable il est
suffisamment grand pour pouvoir monter
confortablement dessus
le trackpad est sympa que dire d'autre
le retour à l'ancien système de clavier
qui est confortable pour j'avais rien
contre l'ancien même si la cour s'était
était un peu courte
là on retrouve des claviers avec une
course un peu plus importante et avec
aussi apparemment beaucoup moins de
problèmes de toucher de fonctionnement
puisque les anciens modèles avait ce
genre de soucis bref physiquement il a
tout pour être une super stations de
montage en mobilité
mais est-ce que niveau performances ça
suit est ce que nos performances on se
retrouve à quelque chose qui va nous
permettre de travailler sur des fichiers
4 cas sur l'étalonnage sur des effets un
petit peu poussé bats pour ça j'ai
demandé à un expert un de nous faire un
petit comparatif et nous parler un petit
peu performances pures de ce macbook pro
c'est pousse j'ai nommé didier de mac
forever didier c'est à tous salut
françois l'or comme tu le sais j'ai
testé donc ce magot process pouces sous
toutes ses coutures dès sa sortie c'est
vrai que j'ai été assez impressionné par
les performances
déjà au niveau du cpu puisque tu sais
qu'on a un modèle donc à 8h sur le haut
de gamme alors en fait il reprend la
même puce un qu'on avait vu l'an dernier
sur le terrain et poussent mais cette
fois ci la machine et mieux refroidie du
coup elle est plus rapide avec le même
processeur et si tu compares par exemple
ici avec ton mac mini de 2018 et ben si
tu prends le core i9 il est largement
devant alors on reste un petit peu quand
même en dessous de la mc sanka qui est
une machine
bureau mais par exemple dans logic ici
on voit qu'on se rapproche quand même
pas mal bref on a quasiment les paires
fin d'un imac dans un macbook ou alors
par contre sur la partie gpu grosse
nouveauté là puisqu'on a donc la
dernière puce amd de la dernière
génération gravé à cette nano m et là
franchement françois ça envoie du steak
puisqu'on est quasiment deux fois plus
rapide que les gpu précédent dans l'est
dans l'es15 tous d'avant par exemple ici
sous resolve on est même presque au
niveau d'un imac 5 avec sa petite vega
48 et le moindre macbook pro 13 pouces
ou même ton mac mini là avec les gpu
intel ici dans des tests comme ça ils
sont tout simplement mais explosé
françois je sais que tu es un gros
bosseur mais je sais aussi que tu aimes
de temps en temps tu as tu es un petit
peu du mulot et c'est vrai qu'on peut
jouer avec cette carte alors faut pas
espérer de la 4k mais en 1080 avec les
détails quand même assez élevé ça passe
plutôt pas mal même si j'ai tendance à
conseiller quand même de jouer sur
windows
si tu veux vraiment des meilleures perfs
mais là tu vois qu'on est au niveau d'un
imac avec un portable moi je trouve ça
quand même hyper cool donc vraiment un
très très bon gpu cette année alors bien
sûr on a fait pas mal de tests sous
final cut là je te montre quelques
exemples avec des effets avec la machine
à huit coeurs avec le plus gros gpu et
tu vois qu'on est quatre fois plus
rapide qu'un 13 pouces 1 ça donne un
petit peu une idée ou qu'un mac mini
haut de gamme par exemple ici avec un
projet 4k puis des effets de flou et de
contrastes tu vois qu'on n'est pas très
loin non plus delaema qu'on arrive même
à le dépasser ainsi tu prends vraiment
la config max donc là vraiment encore
une fois on a des performances assez
exceptionnelle aussi bien sur la partie
gpu que la partie cpu
voilà moi avec tous les tests que j'ai
fait c'est clair que je vous conseille
le 8 heures pour la vidéo c'est le
minimum c'est pas forcément le haut de
gamme on a vu qu'il n'est pas trop trop
de différence par contre prenez aussi le
gpu haut de gamme de préférence avec les
8 giga de mémoire surtout si vous faites
des groupes projets sous resolve the
after et serra qui demande quand même
pas mal de mémoire vidéo
en tout cas voilà c'est une machine
qu'on va garder longtemps donc ça vaut
le coup des fois de mettre un petit peu
de budget voilà françois donc au
quotidien je n'ai aucun problème pour
éditer des vidéos même en 4k même avec
des effets même mec de l'étalonnage il
aucun souci la bécane elle encaisse sans
broncher au delà de ça je vous ai parlé
donc de la mobilité qui est une
contrainte que je peux pas éviter mais
je n'ai pas pour autant revendu mon gpu
mon écran externe mon clavier m'a souri
mon rêve bref tout ce que je vous avais
présenté dans la vidéo sur le mac mini
ce qui fait que non seulement on et
confort en mobilité mais en plus de ça
quand je rentre à la maison on est
encore plus confort le hic gpu même s'il
ne change pas complètement la donne un
faux pas non plus se leurrer c'est pas
quelque chose de magique
ça soulage énormément la machine
puisqu'il prend le relais par rapport à
la carte graphique interne qui est
vraiment pas mal de la carte graphique
est vraiment sympa l écran de 27 pouces
c'est aussi quand même super confort
avec en plus le dual screen puisque je
peux avoir l'écran du macbook en
simultané et l'écran du 27 pouces donc
on peut mettre sur final cut 12 fenêtres
différentes une avec la timeline par
exemple et une avec la preview et puis
il a cédé deux ports thunderbolt roy a
branché est terminée qu'on dira ce qu'on
veut sur l'absence des ports des
nouveaux macbook le thunderbolt roi ça
reste hyper pratique même si j'ai une
petite réserve que je vous garde pour la
fin bref pour moi en mobilité s'écoule à
la maison c'est cool aussi mais on en
vient à notre dernier point ce macbook
est ce qu'il est fait pour vous bat pour
répondre à cette question il faut penser
à mon avis rentabilité au-delà du fait
de si vous voulez juste vous faire
plaisir et vous achetez la bécane qui
est super si vous n'avez pas d'impératif
de montage ou des dites en mobilité
c'est sûr que il n'ya pas vraiment
d'intérêt à m quatre mille balles dans
un appareil comme ça là je vous renvoie
à la config avec le mac mini qui est
vraiment super bien en plus d'être hyper
évolutive parce que dans le macbook on
change rien dedans c'est fini c'était la
belle époque où on change et l'arabe les
ssd les machins
terminer dans mon cas clairement c'était
hyper intéressant parce que ça me permet
d'être plus performants d'être plus
rapide dans la livraison de mes vidéos
ou de mes photos sans perte de puissance
ou de confort pour le travail ne serait
ce que le fait qu'il ait huit coeurs
plus la carte graphique
enfin il enterre le mac mini forcément
mais avec tous les ajouts que je lui
avais fait le mac mini jeux des merdes
est pas mal quand même franchement il
tenait il tenait la comparaison parce
que clairement c'est une machine qui
s'adresse aux pros là je sais que ça va
faire hurler des gens à bout procès pour
les pros et agro débat gros débat mais à
mon sens c'est une machine qui n'a de
sens que si on est professionnel si on
ne l'est pas on peut très bien se
contenter de quelque chose d'un peu
moins puissant puisqu'on n'aura pas
d'impératif de temps on sera beaucoup
moins speed on pourra avoir des machines
qui vont faire le taf un peu moins vite
peut-être un peu moins bien mais qui
vont faire le taf quand même le seul
truc
et là je sais que ça aussi ça fait débat
sur lequel je trouve que c'est un petit
peu abusé de la part d'apple qui
s'adresse justement avec une machine
pour les pros je ne comprends pas qu
encore là en 2020 on est plus de port sd
sur une machine dite pro alors ok on à
l'usb type c on peut brancher
directement sa caméra sur le mac pour
récupérer les fichiers mais honnêtement
moi ma caméra elle est sur son trépied
donc ça va aussi vite d'enlever la carte
sd de prendre un adaptateur et de le
brancher sur le sbc
il y aurait encore une étape en moins
avec un port sd pour le mettre
directement dans le mac là ça serait
juste parfait il ya quand même
énormément de professionnels qui
utilisent les cartes sd et qui seraient
ravis d'avoir encore un port sd que ce
soient photographes que ce soit vidéaste
une machine eu trop sans port sd je
trouve ça un tout petit peu radin et
pour finir je pense qu'en fonction du
budget c'est une machine qui va falloir
gonfler un petit peu pour qu'elle dure
vraiment dans le temps c'est à dire
prendre une carte graphique puissante
le processeur c'est pas forcément
indispensable parce que au final on se
rend compte dans les différents belge
qu' il n'y a pas une grande différence
et puis que comme le processeur haut de
gamme a tendance à chauffer plus bas
le mcs réduit un petit peu sa cadence
donc le premier processeur va bien 32
gigas de ram pour moi pour voir l'avenir
je pense que c'est la meilleure solution
64 c'est peut-être pas encore
indispensable et puis sur cette gamme
apple a vraiment fait un effort sur le
prix des ssd c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
pris 1 2 tera c'est aussi pour ne plus
avoir à me trimbaler de disques externes
même si j'en prends au cas où mais je
peux tout mettre sur l'ordi faire tous
mes montages même plusieurs montages sur
les deux terrains je suis vraiment à
l'aise puis je vide de temps en temps
les différents projets là pour le coup
ça vaut le coup de passer sur au moins
un terrain et profiter du confort de ne
pas avoir à brancher deux disques
externes pour monter là on peut vraiment
tout faire dedans et cd disques qui sont
hyper rapide donc ça permet de profiter
de toute l'expérience au final 2-2 ce
macbook pro qui est vraiment une super
machine une super stations de montage
mobile et voilà les amis on a fait le
tour je pense de ce que je voulais vous
dire sur ce macbook on n'est pas partis
dans tous les détails fiche technique et
tous les petits machins parce que c'est
pas quelque chose qui moi me paraît
toujours hyper pertinent l'importante
pour moi c'est l'expérience utilisateur
et est-ce qu'en tant que vidéaste on
peut y arriver avec cette machine là à
faire des trucs chouettes et avoir de la
puissance et en avoir sous le pied oui
la réponse est oui c'est une super bonne
bécane mais pas adressé à tout le monde
est en tout cas les amis j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu si c'est le
cas vous n'hésitez pas à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo vous pouvez
laïque et commentez vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait activer la cloche
pour ne rien rater de ce qui va venir
plus tard et puis moi je vous dis les
amis comme d'habitude rester curieux et
à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
j'ai un peu honte pour le café mais j'ai
essayé j'ai fait de mon mieux voilà
c'est et puis paf
la rechute quoi la rechute est tombé
dedans la et
et voilà c'est vous avez des trucs pour
compenser le café le thé ça marche pas
la verveine peut-être tilleuls tilleul
menthe
1c'est mais on va y arriver